[Aplausos]
reino unido- estrena primera ministra
tras ganar las elecciones del partido
conservador listos asumirá como la jefa
del ejecutivo británico y ya lo hará
después de su reunión con la reina
isabel segunda la primera tarea de todos
será nombrar a sus ministros se espera
que la primera reunión del ejecutivo se
celebre el miércoles 7 de septiembre
antes de la sesión semanal de preguntas
a la primera ministra en la cámara de
los comunes por otra parte enfrentará
difíciles situaciones como el fuerte
incremento del precio de la energía y la
inflación interanual británica que se
sitúa en el 10 1 por ciento pero que el
banco de inglaterra anticipo que puede
llegar al 13 por ciento a finales de
2022 y para conversar de este tema hoy
nos acompaña desde londres oscar
guardiola él es profesor de birkbeck
college university of london bienvenidos
a france 24 un placer saludarlo en esta
mañana de martes para nuestra audiencia
y en su tarde que tanto margen de acción
tiene la nueva primera ministra ante la
crisis económica que podría terminar
el margen de acción de la nueva primera
ministra británica es ciertamente
limitado de una parte va a intentar
establecer una suerte de control de
precios en particular en el sector
energético pero ese control de precios
tan solo sería temporal y de todas
maneras va a caer en últimas en manos de
los de quienes pagamos nuestros
impuestos así que la crisis que ya todos
esperamos va a hacerse realidad y es
poco probable que la primera ministra
pueda evitarla y se espera que ella
anuncie un paquete para rescatar a las
personas más vulnerables del reino
unido- por 115 mil millones de dólares
que tan efectivo puede ser esto para
contrarrestar esa inflación y el aumento
de los precios de la energía
el efecto de esas medidas va a ser
limitado de una parte porque hay que
contrastar la con la ayuda de casi 40
billones que ya se ha anunciado para las
corporaciones y el
el descenso en los impuestos que también
va a ser dirigido en particular a
quienes más ganan de otra parte ya la
inflación ha aumentado ya estamos
sintiendo el costo en energía en
alimentos en educación en nuestros
bolsillos y para hacer más claridad
acerca de las estimaciones que se hacen
acerca del proceso inflacionario en gran
bretaña si bien es cierto que ya estamos
en 10% y se espera que llegue a un 13%
al final del año otras predicciones muy
serias están hablando de 18 por ciento y
hasta 20 por ciento lo que
pondría a gran bretaña en la misma
situación problemática que ya vivió en
los 70s y se esperaba ya en el campo
político que el nuevo primer ministro
fuera de una ala política más distinta a
la de boris johnson porque recordemos
que este premier renunció ante las
presiones por los escándalos por las
fiestas que se realizaron en downing
street durante la pandemia sin embargo
el listado será de las candidatas más
cercanas al antiguo primer ministro en
ese sentido que tanto se puede
diferenciar de johnson
en realidad muy poco de hecho hoy mismo
el antiguo primer ministro boris johnson
se comparó a sí mismo con uno de los
políticos miembros del senado romano que
luego regresaron como dictadores y aquí
circula la idea de acuerdo con la cual
la razón por la cual tomó tanto tiempo a
los conservadores elegir a una nueva
líder de su partido habría sido para
evitar que boris johnson fuese el primer
ministro con menor tiempo de duración y
por lo tanto más identificable con la
incompetencia de la historia lo que ya
implica que estaría planeando su retorno
y eso va a crearles serios problemas al
strauss porque va a llenar su
gabinete con personas que van a ser más
leales a boris johnson que a ella misma
está en verdad invitada a intentar
administrar una 'tormenta perfecta'
y sigamos hablando de comparaciones
porque se ha dicho mucho que el estrés
podría hacer la nueva margaret thatcher
porque al igual que ocurrió con la dama
de hierro está recibiendo un reino unido
en una crisis casi que sin precedentes y
ella misma se declara admiradora sin
embargo más que ser dama de hierro ella
parece tener un papel más camaleónico en
la política pues pasó de ser una liberal
demócrata y de criticar a la monarquía a
ser ahora una de las alas del partido
conservador que tan similar puede ser
uno entonces a margaret thatcher
las comparaciones con margaret thatcher
solamente llegan hasta donde llega su
escasa credibilidad y la credibilidad de
lo que es en últimas un giro puramente
publicitario se le conoce como alguien
que ha cambiado como bien lo decías de
posición política y partido muchas veces
desde
posiciones más hacia la izquierda que
critican la monarquía hasta ser miembro
del partido liberaldemócrata
ahora del luego del centro moderado del
partido conservador y ahora del ala más
ultraderechista la que apoya también a
boris johnson eso de una parte y de la
otra al contrario de marca de thatcher
listados ha probado ser una comunicadora
mucho menos eficiente y además recibe al
país en circunstancias muy diferentes
marca de tacha y recibe el país en
crisis tras
gobiernos laboristas el cambio el
strauss lo recibe tras casi una de una
casi dos décadas de gobierno conserva va
a ser muy difícil para ella distanciarse
del pasado como sí pudo hacerlo margaret
thatcher y por último la atracción de
una figura como margaret thatcher y lo
que representaba en términos de política
económica ciertamente ya no captura la
atención y la fascinación del público
británico como lo hizo en aquella época
y otro de los cambios de postura de
listos fue frente al break sheet ella
inicialmente voto en contra de que los
británicos se separaran de la unión
europea y luego ha dicho abiertamente
que se arrepiente de haber votado así y
de hecho ha sido una de las impulsoras
de la norma que le permitiría a londres
incumplir el acuerdo que tiene con
bruselas ante este panorama que se
espera entre la relación de reino unido
con la unión europea
de nuevo estas posiciones novedosas por
parte del listado se han sido percibidas
en gran bretaña más bien como formas de
oportunismo político le habría sido
imposible posicionarse dentro del
partido conservador
de otra manera pero también es cierto
que tanto dentro del partido conservador
como en otros
aspectos del espectro político ya se
reconoce que las promesas de brasil son
promesas fallidas que la relación con
europa tiene que enmendar se hay
conservadores que ya están hablando de
la necesidad de pensar en un modelo
económico diferente de relación entre
gran bretaña y europa lo que podría ser
la reentrada del reino unido- en la zona
económica si bien no en la unión ahora
bien
hacerlo sería un suicidio político para
el strauss así que vamos a seguir viendo
cómo se vuelve más problemática la
relación entre europa y gran bretaña y
europa ha sido o se ha mostrado muy
abierta y sin embargo los problemas en
irlanda del norte van a complicar las
cosas